[Music]
you get up in the morning you're really
excited you're prepared you need a good
breakfast you've thought about your
audience your intent your message you're
ready to go it's a good point Towanda
we're gonna get to that how many of us
have seen the speaker interrupted we've
all seen heard of or even been at one
time a speaker loses control of the
speaker's presentation because of
unexpected behavior from individuals in
the audience we realize that you can
lose a lot of credibility this way which
will prevent you from connecting with
your audience effectively achieving your
intent or conveying clearly the message
that you have for your audience if you
are a speaker who wants to learn how to
more effectively respond with power then
we invite you listen to us as we share
some tips on how you can deal with these
there are three things that we'll talk
about today one is how do you deal with
interruptions from the audience the
second is how do you interrupt some
people who are rambling on the
containers that are really not missing
and finally how do you deal with those
ubiquitous digital distractions like
atoms tinder swipes
firstly we'll talk about interruptions
all of us know that the that there are
three reasons but why people interrupt
us first of all some high status
individuals might think that they've got
far more interesting things to say then
you the speaker
secondly people might just not have an
idea of where you're going with your
presentation
and have questions pop up in their mind
and lastly there might be some time
sensitive questions that they have that
they urgently need to raise with you so
what can you do about this firstly
preempt the instructor make it clear to
your audience right at the beginning how
you would like them to bring up their
questions or inquiries with you
secondly make sure that you have a very
clear agenda or roadmap on what you're
going to discuss so people know that
you'll address their questions if people
are finally next speak with confidence
and speak loudly so that people know
that's not really inconvenient to
interrupt you when they're thinking of
doing that torna I think that's a really
interesting point if someone does insist
on interrupting you use phrasing that
makes it change them but you prefer not
to be in shock that way I'd like that
if someone does interrupt you make sure
that if it's something that's
distracting to the entire audience you
say to them we can take this offline and
deal with it in a one-on-one
conversation and finally if this
continues on and on and on
enlist the support of the group to ask
guys is there a way that we can more
effectively communicate cuz you're
probably not the only one who's
frustrated by someone who's difficult it
reminds me of this time such a good
point the other day when I was walking
through town square and Ellison
introduced me to a rod it was so
interesting I mean it was like here's
the new person that we are our points
are really healthy we'll be there right
someone like Kevin stop talking Iran
goes on and on how do you respond
how do you deal with that well it's
helpful to understand what's happening
inside cavity so getting my start on the
topic you might start speaking about
what's actually relevant for the
conversation but as he starts speaking
his body especially if he's speaking
about something personal about his own
experience will start to produce
dopamine dopamine is a normal connected
to pleasure so the more cadence Peaks
the battery feels and he keeps on going
on and when he sees that the audience is
starting to disengage well in ease in
mind the only way to bring them back is
to talk even more so what can we do well
we can interrupt and psychology tells us
that the best way to do that is to
actually listen to a word they were
saying repeat summarize in order 12 them
drive to the conclusion it's a way to
make the interruption feel adequate and
helpful to the speaker that way
especially if we're in a meeting that
happens regularly is to agree on a say
for now we found our challenge and you
can also bring a little object to that
to a meaning now we chose jellyfish
because it's an animal that flows around
in the ocean doesn't really know where
it's going but if you choose any fun
word interrupting the Rambler we become
fun rather than chilled rude and you
probably would get more people join in
because they will feel that it's
actually polite is actually proper to
deliver your me and with that I will
pass it on to Danielle speak about
digital interruptions so you've heard a
couple ways that your presentation can
go awry that are louder someone
instructs you you need to interrupt
something else but what about a quieter
distraction when people are just not
paying attention because they're on
their phones or their laptops we've
heard in other presentations today how
important it can be to keep people's
attention when they're distracted by
digital
Isis so I'm going to share three ways to
do that the first is to set ground rules
you have the power to say up front that
you want to have a laptop screen meeting
and ask everybody to shut their laptops
and focus on the topic at hand another
strategy to set the ground rules is to
actually have everybody take out their
phone and lay it on the table in the
middle of the room that makes it much
harder to reach for your phone and start
texting in the middle of a meeting
because everybody will see what you're
doing so you can try that out next time
you have a meeting the second tip is to
give a reason why you need people's
attention if people feel like their
contribution is really important to the
meeting they're less likely to be
distracted on their phone or computer
because they know that they have
something to add so when you call
somebody out for being on their phone
you can say hey I really need you to pay
attention because your input is so
important to this decision and so if
you're on your phone we can't have the
discussion we need to have on that note
it's important to make sure that
everybody in your meeting really does
need to be there because if somebody's
on their phone or laptop it might be
because they feel like their input isn't
actually needed and you should ask
yourself that question is there somebody
you can take off of your meeting invite
or maybe you can just have your meeting
over email because the meeting doesn't
actually need to happen in person it's
really important to make sure that
everybody's attention actually is
required so they're less likely to be
distracted and finally decide when and
how to interrupt the person who's
distracted so you might decide that it's
not that important and you want to let
them know after the meeting or it could
be really crucial in the moment like it
is right now hey Kevin
your input is so important in this
presentation so I really need you to be
off your phone if that's all right
in fact it's time for you to deliver the
we've all been there things happen when
we present by using some of these
suggestions and being mindful of ways
that you can respond with power you can
help determine what happens after that
it's really interesting in terms of
sometimes you can be interrupted
continuing on sometimes your audience
members might start telling a story you
might need to potentially interrupt them
this is really important to do Kevin
then reminds me I was on vacation in
Greece and you were there to remember
that and we were talking about
interruption and jellyfish Thank You
Brady beautiness remember to use the
safe word and lastly to engage with that
ubiquitous world of digital devices that
we sometimes find there we talked about
a couple weeks ago during the
presentation you know we thanks for the
reminder
sure and with that we're ready to take
your questions
[Music]